welcome to another episode of not too
deep with me your host grace Helbig the
first today we have Chris here I know I
am pumped as much as you are you know
him from you are the worst he's in
Modern Family
he's in an upcoming curious Pokemon
situation we're gonna get into that in a
little bit also turns out he is the
greatest husband and father of all time
so get ready to fall in love if you
haven't already with the one and only
Chris gear on this episode of not too
deep so I love reality TV I love trash
television and whoa see what's that I do
as well
Oh we'll get there I know you guys have
gorgeous short which blew my mind I have
to get into I haven't even started yet
but I hear it's gonna it's gonna take
years away from my life as soon as I
actually invest in it but no hard knocks
is like the closest I get to like
following football because it shows like
them in their training season yeah and
they are like children they're like
they're like teenagers they're in their
mid-20s early to mid-20s who've been
handed everything yeah they've only had
one focus their whole life is just the
sport and you question how much kind of
guidance they pads right I mean of
course taking their parents aside how
much of the of their time is spent with
with people who've experienced that kind
of lifestyle and to use it to their best
advantage because you see all these
incredible players who kind of they lose
their way great and I think that happens
in the acting profession as well I mean
if you think if you hit a success too
soon yeah it's your agent calling saying
don't get too deep no I I think if you
don't know someone that has wisdom that
has experience that can provide you
some alternative perspective on what
you're doing that is carried away right
because they only know that this is
exactly what they're gonna do in their
minds for the rest of their lives that's
not really a sports equivalent of a
child actor basically yeah did you do
acting as a child no no I'm actually
really grateful I didn't actually I was
I didn't I didn't have a childhood I had
a childhood yeah sports you know I
wouldn't build tree houses and ran
around in your imagination imagination I
was into art and I was into just
inventing games and creating you know we
used to be in early yeah you fill in all
the blanks you had to create the blanks
for yourself you to fill in the space
between dinner and and then going to bed
that's what I'm trying my sons now
nearly six yeah generation right yeah so
he's the the iPad that we that we allow
him to have on special occasions he's
he's he's watching stuff which is of
course we're monitoring sure and it's
educational it's informative or whatever
and it's fun so combining all those
things but he would happily stay on it
all week really we don't go go outside
was conditioned to that right yeah so
it's yeah I remember seeing a video of
like a two-year-old with a Time magazine
swiping the pages like it was an iPad
because that's what the kid was
conditioned to before goes to bed it
just as a screen and you move things
around and I said to him like wouldn't
you go and build a fort he doesn't know
what a fort is I'm inside anyway I have
shelter already why am i building a
shelter within my shelter I'm not an
idiot dad why don't you build a fort
take what you build the fall I'll come
and visit you
okay well this wouldn't ask you about
football
I watched the Renaldo documentary like a
year ago
and I loved it but then I showed it to
my boyfriend and he was like this is a
puff piece it's produced by Ronaldo less
insane and then Ronaldo got his total
tax thing and all of that happened but
that was a person that was like oh he's
playing this sport like for his dad like
he's playing it for like a legacy a
legacy and also he's being a wonderful
dad to like his son seemingly this you
know documentary and so it's insane to
me to watch them compete in World Cup
which only happens once every four years
right yeah yeah and then watching all
these people rally around these like mid
20 year olds that are the pressures
insane
yeah who in you know on the Madonn in
the majority they are in four years time
when the next World Cup rolls along
they'll be past it right
they're out of it so they know they've
really only got one real stab at one
moment in time yeah unless you're
Ronaldo cuz the guy's smart the guys
like the epitome of professional you ran
out of in yeah thank you for you messy
or you've been the new guy I had to
write this down because I just saw
because I know look look look lo que lo
que lo que one that just learned a bad
guy from Thor good goal and then he says
this really passive-aggressive mean
thing about you but no there's a new guy
that completely destroyed their streak
cuz he a mess you go back and forth for
like Player of the Year and so
apparently some new guy won this year
Wow
yeah this it must have been well done
Messi you've always been the kind of the
ones that clash
I think Macy's an outstanding talent is
he's possibly the greatest player of all
time I think simply because of how much
how much of the pitch he covers he's
he's exceptional Ronaldo has been in
three World Cups
misquote me on this I think like for
European Championships and he there was
a picture that went out of him with his
shirt off after a goal celebration I've
never seen so many pack and then in some
press thing they showed a picture of him
from eight years ago he looks exactly
the same
he dunno eight years of maintaining that
I mean I can go I can go from quite fit
to absolutely horrific chicken wings
later and apparently what he does is
after each game he's got a he's got a
cryotherapy lab yes in his house yeah so
your freezers raises himself a little
bit and then always does 200 lengths in
his of course private swimming pool yeah
and then he's got a nutrition he's got
all the people behind him to formula
Chris I don't know how you can't do it
just pay a gazillion people did you lose
your mind I mean cuz you live here now
in Los Angeles yes you've been here for
how long I've been here well on and off
for five years we still have we have a
base in England and then I come here for
work and wait yeah we're currently
looking for houses to make the big move
to make the big move
okay that's exciting which is exciting I
think I needed firstly we were lucky
with the show that it went for five
years cuz five years ago I didn't know
it would ray and then over that time I
the main thing for me is that my wife
and son were happy here ya know that's
very huge things what was the main thing
yeah otherwise it would become a life of
them five thousand miles away yeah which
I think we we've handled exceptionally
well and my wife is incredibly
understanding and supportive um I don't
mean in a robe but I didn't
you know internet stalking as you
Jennifer
I was drunk oh yeah your wife is
Jennifer yes um her Instagram bio and if
this is a joke it's very funny but if it
says if this is real I need to know the
story behind this she's the 2018 wedding
industry Awards National winner let me
tell you about this please do penis
she's a pianist she started off as a
like working in bars and things and then
she would bid like and then she became a
jazz pianist she's also classically
trained got a voice and plays piano
she's wonderful
played with bands and solo work then
went into corporate the corporate world
which obviously pays a lot better which
then leads to the wedding world and the
wedding world is phenomenally large I
never appreciated how big the wedding
business is would you have a chance to
yeah unless unless you're there you know
I've only been married once but I
remember the day having a lot of people
arranging things for us sure yeah those
people are part of a community where
there there's so much money and so much
kind of bespoke whatever goes into it
that they've created this industry so
the wedding industry is like the the
national awards for weddings so we went
to this place last year where she was
nominated we went along for the free
drinks okay so she was she was playing
at wedding she's playing at weddings and
then she submitted to become a part of
the the wedding industry solo artists of
all the brides and grooms that she
performed for some you know I don't know
how many loads over that year all voted
for her so she made the shortlist okay
we get to Cafe de Perry in London and
Leicester Square uh-huh we go there and
I'm thinking it's gonna be ten people
sat around going hello you do weddings
as well this is great
how's your wedding no there's thousands
of people there I was like oh my
goodness and it went everything from
next up ladies and gentlemen we have the
Award for Best stationer this is great
and all that you know all the stationers
who spent their whole life creating
stationery for weddings going and as it
goes up and obviously Jen's being like
the you know there solo solo artist is
like you know the Best Actress in a
comedy I'm a little bit drunk simply out
of confusion okay well here we go then
and she says I was come out with I mean
Jensen she was very blase about the
whole thing she was never super nervous
she was like this is a bit hilarious
isn't it and she wins and there's all
these other competition around the
outside for you know other solo people
who later will not speak to her because
she's won this award and she goes she
goes up you know everyone goes you've
done it cause everyone knows each other
and right actors mattresses that know
each other and she comes home with this
trophy and it's now on top of the piano
and this is what Jen always says if
you're gonna be a wedding singer be the
best in the country
be an award-winning I mean everyone
loves award-winning that whole world
award-winning this is I would just get
work from being award-winning that's a
thousand percent I mean I started out
doing videography for weddings like when
I lived in New York a little bit as an
award for that I didn't win it I set my
hair on fire with a votive candle one
time
don't win awards accident-prone I ya
know i yeah someone told me I'm mr.
Magoo my way through life that's an
accurate thing I've ever heard about
myself but I'm so happy that that wasn't
a joke I'm so happy that that's an
actual war that she's using legit the
best wedding singer in the country
balance the household now do you feel a
little inferior toward winning wife you
know I've won an award I think I want a
swimming award when I was about 12 she's
got all her trophies all lined up and
I'm like huh she's going back to America
before me I mean I'll have her on an
episode solo so she can give me the
whole thing in that kind of industry she
can work anywhere this is one of the
main draws one international thing
weddings yeah a beautiful British
pianist singer at your wedding I wish
that just followed me around and when
you get married let's do it never
o'clock okay so I want to talk about
you're the worst obviously yeah but I
want to talk too much about it because
this podcast is all about things that
aren't deep and aren't like actually the
things that people want to hear I don't
miss before I cry after sometimes in the
car on the way home from work every day
just just questionable allergies is what
I call it yeah okay so you finish you've
wrapped completely shooting oh no it'd
have you had a full hand on like the
experience are you still in that state
where you it's hard to reflect on any of
it because are we tail fresh I had a
text exchange with aya who plays my
co-star yes yeah and both of us are
feeling a little bit lost because you
stranger could you mention before when
you guys started this Jordan no idea
would last five seasons you had no idea
like the audience it would be gardener
you had no idea like what your lives
would end up being and I'm sure you guys
must have formed a very close bond with
each other we did and you know it's so
cliched so you've got a family but it is
you know we we
built a relationship over five years we
all came in really nervous and excited
and wanting to make the most of this
amazing script yeah and at the end of
each season we hugged each other as if
to say well that was a good run but we
know what the current climate is like
people get the shows get axed and you
the actors find out via Twitter yeah you
know that's that's how it is these days
so to get the call five years running
that we were going to come back was
amazing to know that we were going to
finish on our terms is the rarest thing
yeah I mean you know you to chase the
dragon yeah that it seems like I mean
crew wise cast eyes everyone that's
there must everyone came back for the
last season everyone started the show
crew wise and all came back because they
wanted to finish where they started it's
incredibly sweet so the last the last
day I mean desi who plays Edgar he was
like it's like moving out of a your
family home and you don't want to yeah
you just you have to move you have to
move house place the lease is up and and
it's it's really really weird cuz I
wrapped Modern Family in the in the same
week so it was saying goodbye to these
these these people I'd love to [ __ ]
yeah and this is the I think it's the
trickiest part of the industry really is
that in between II bit well that's I was
gonna ask you because I mean I know
being on set you if you probably sit
down and you mark out the amount of time
that you've spent on set versus like at
home majority is spent with these people
on this show and the in-between part is
the weirdest part to me is like the most
human part of it all where you guys now
are no longer like going to a job every
day with each other but now you get to
like Interactive's friends and like keep
up with each other just in life where
what you want to wear and you're not in
costume and you're not in makeup and
you're not in a on a set gray you go do
you want to go for lunch
what do we like if we get coffee with
each other running lines revealing what
is that world look like it's very
strange there was a best friend is
actress Betty Gilpin who's in glow and
she wrote this wonderful article
recently about about the difference
between how how strange it is when you
are working and how difficult it is when
you're not because yeah you go from
immediate sunset you have a you have a
trailer and a PA and all these people
that are rushing around to let's be
honest make sure that you're in the
right place at the right time that's
what they're doing
yeah and but it's it's exciting and you
know I'd love a coffee please that would
be lovely I normally make it myself now
you're making me why this is wonderful
very much didn't you enjoy that and then
suddenly you finish and no one really
cares no one no one's there no one tells
you what you should be doing where you
should be doing how you should be
standing what you should be saying all
this and then you have to train yourself
to become individual again a human again
human again yeah because in a way you're
kind of you're you're manipulated into
whatever the production needs you to be
right and is glamorous and like that is
you're playing your part in a system
that's you know operating with so many
parts - it's a business yeah and then
you go alright okay so when we got to
the wrap party
and everyone's there and everyone elects
their hair down and we're like yeah
actually you know what work aside I'm
really fond of you and that's what was
sad knowing that we're not going to have
that massive group dye amount dynamic
again yeah we'll bump into each other
again but and arrange to me Arthur
optimistically speaking you didn't have
the moment of like I cannot wait to get
away from me there are people that do
that yeah and I got parties alike I was
cool oh it's called like 11:00 p.m. once
you've got past the niceties and yeah
and they show the the gag reel maybe
maybe a little snippet of the first
episode so everyone could get excited -
oh yeah the free dress drinks are
flowing and then I call it gloves off
some some dude from Haiti and everyone's
allowed to say whatever never liked you
they said you were a dick
luckily I've never been on the on the
wrong side of that but it's the truth
serum yeah it's very very much truth
serum but it seems like I mean the show
feels cohesive enough and obviously like
has such an engaged audience because it
seems like you guys have real
friendships on screen and off yeah and
I'm sorry that that's ending I've
learned an awful lot from it in terms of
there was you know the press of very
kindly or was spoken about our chemistry
as a four eyes or two and and someone
asked me once like how do you how do you
make that chemistry and you know people
have always said it's is something that
just happens or doesn't happen not I
don't agree with that I think that
chemistry comes from whoever's involved
really caring about what you're doing
yeah cuz if you if you really if you
want to be there if you want to make the
best of what you're doing that is
chemistry that's the connection that you
need like I work on sets on films or
whatever sometimes and you can tell when
someone's not there yeah when they're
not a hundred percent kind of involved
in whatever they're doing
mm-hm and that's obvious these days
cameras are too good Bell Bell notice
transparency and the idea that like this
is your number one priority your present
and you care and that there is an equal
level of caring and that's like respect
on a certain level like I respect you
enough to care so much about this
project as much as you do yeah well it's
all coming to an end wonderful when we
get back I have some more very deep
hard-hitting light-hearted questions for
Chris here we'll be right back with more
not too deep
[Music]
to deep support for today's episode of
not too deep comes from third love using
millions of real women's measurements
third love designs its bras with breast
size and shape in mind for an impeccable
fit an incredible feel just answer a few
simple questions from third loves fit
finder quiz to find your perfect fit
third love offers double the number of
sizes that most brands offer cups a
through H and bands up to 48 and with
light weight memory foam cups straps
that won't slip and tagless labels
you'll want to wear these soft and
breathable bras and underwear every day
especially the new cotton t-shirt bras
and underwear but thanks to the 100% fit
guarantee returns and exchanges are free
and easy you guys know me I'm a creature
of comfort over sports bras as if I play
for like the women's soccer team I don't
but when third love sent me some of
their bras I actually finally found some
decent feminine feeling bras that also
were incredibly comfortable and didn't
make me feel like I had a weird
underwire situation you know I mean just
go check it out I highly recommend them
they know that there's a perfect bra for
everyone so right now they're offering
you beautiful listeners 15% off your
first order go to 3rd love.com slash
grace now to find your perfect fitting
bra and get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love comm such grace for
15% off today you guys I think have an
easier led to an American accent then I
feel like I've anyone that is American
unless they're very well trained it
sounds like a cartoon no it sounds like
rude doing an English accent however I
do have some English friends that when I
ask them like what's your American
accent every single time I've asked an
English friend to do it this sentence
whatever sentence they arbitrarily
choose includes cheeseburger yes
hamburger yes
and a min I mean America Americans often
sound like I mean Beth does it as well
actually which is gone do a British
accent it's like or blimey it's summer
now have Oliver you know Mary Poppins
yeah I get called out because I my
friends have called me out and every
time I've gone to England that I mimic
without knowing then I mimic and so I'll
be like oh yeah so call me out if that
happens during this podcast you can ask
me a question with your British accent
oh boy what's your guilty pleasure is
hearing you do I got cut out of the
Harry Potter series now in English what
is your guilty pleasure what is my girls
probably cookery shows really okay do
you watch Great British Bake Off yeah
okay very very yeah I didn't think any
British person is obsessed as the
American public seem to be they love it
yeah because you're British baking shows
okay a great British Bake Off
it seems very refined it seems very
respectful of people and like actually
aeronaut exploitative just a really
gentle sweet selection of its gentle
making cakes yeah and then we have Guy
Fieri that's like wow I mean this is how
I got into Caprichos I was watching I
think he's fantastic I called Adam
Richmond who did amazing
but you know he can't do it anymore cuz
he hurt his body so much doing yes I
mean it was abuse of the body
I mean I got a big one today I'm gonna
try and do like twenty five thousand
chicken wings
the most American show of all time a man
is going to hurt himself irreversibly
physical damage yes yes for the sake of
entertainment a ton of weight now he's
doing other projects he's still into
still into chicken wings a thing I mean
that's that's that's comforting I think
a guilty pleasure should be something
that kind of distracts you from your
normal life or the broken world as it is
I think the the just cooking shows shows
me I mean I love cooking myself I love
it but just just watching them the way
that I mean you can you can make stuff
or you can make stuff that was just sign
language that's ASL American Sign
Language for make it sexy how they get
you know the curbs and then choking them
in a pan you're like this is good too I
have a couple friends sorted food is
their YouTube channel and they do
cooking in you know in London and
they're trying to make a big kind of
just kind of spot like the fact that
like English food gets a bad rap yeah
and but now it's kind of having like a
moment so to speak where there's like
restaurants and you know Jamie Oliver is
really kind of like pushing this English
I still think English food is all right
I think the multicultural society of
London is now so good they're the best
chefs from everywhere Arius countries
are coming there and and widening our
horizons our palate so whatever but I
still respect that an English breakfast
just beans on toast is like the biggest
cure of a hangover that I've ever had so
I don't think you guys should change
something that isn't broke yeah
absolutely we kind of like the the kings
and queens of slow cooking as well
there's a lot of I mean you never in 100
degree weather
Los Angeles you don't you don't often
crave a stew or
yeah but in England as it's raining most
of the time if not snowing you're
looking for something that's that's
really hearty and I think that's where
British food is really good they make
stuff which is we're like that we're
like that the head of hangover cures you
guys really I mean I respect like London
is a city that I would love to live in
it feels like a a semi-sweet or New York
City everyone also knows how to drink
there appropriately they start at five
pubs close at 11:00 everyone's up by
8:00 ready for their day jobs like kids
yeah it's an amazingly functioning
machine you go to New York and they're
like we don't sleep ever I went to Vegas
recently they really don't sleep there
oh well we'd finish the show and it was
my best friend's 40th birthday so I went
to met him and his wife I don't really
think you could do more than 24 hours in
Vegas without questioning your existence
yeah without losing part of your soul to
Vegas it was a crazy place but speaking
of food of the food there was incredible
yeah they have everything everything
they do Angelis they seem to open a new
restaurant every every day yeah it's
true if you leave your house you find
that out yeah I know you guys that Post
mates in England no we don't have post
mates we don't have goober really you
know the uber well I live I live in on
the outskirts of Manchester got it okay
so there's there's no need for that
right and there's no need for food
delivery services really anyway it's
like it's like when everyone's preparing
for the war or just buys loads and loads
of tins and we stay in tonight team
carrots tinned peaches what should we
make
what about carrot alla peach let's work
it together
I mean scared of stepping out feeling
comfortable yeah scared of trusting that
things are gonna be okay
different yeah oh I'm gonna go first I
really got into Vietnamese over here
okay yes delicious it's it's kind of
healthy is it is great yeah I have it
like two three times a week sometimes
okay if I went back home and went mum
you need to try some Vietnamese oh is it
in they come at different times I mean
it's such a long way
Chris such a long way no really it's
like a 10-hour flat own mentality of
I've got my house now my house forever
I've got a car yeah but you bought your
car in 1985 still got a car I'm just
gonna hold on to this car I like how
resolute they are I mean there's
something really nice and not being so
wishy-washy and just being steadfast in
what you have I know I think there's
there's a good balance to find where you
know their generation is very much kind
of I am Who I am
yeah Titan would take me as you do I'm
not changing that's what that generates
it's like for all the floors that's kind
of the truth and then ours is
something's broken I'm not gonna try and
fix it I'll go and buy a new one
acknowledge that something doesn't work
but instead of actually spending time to
make this work another one or maybe it's
still within warranty I don't know that
we yeah we got a Walmart get another one
well here's my question
what do your so you went to school for
art right uh-huh
like traditional arts like painting it
was it was a college where I yeah I took
subjects that I enjoyed so I did I did
Performing Arts okay a bit of acting
that's what my sister says and then and
then history of art okay and then
graphic design okay so she was she was
like also you do a bit of acting bit of
drawing bit of painting pretty much so
you just went to like child school you
have to preschool for an adult it wasn't
really the add all of the the academic
of the family I wanted to do stuff or I
could kind of express things but now
what does your sister say about what
you're doing now oh yeah they're all
they're all super proud and also also
the favor I can I'm working here they
can come and visit if they want to which
is great I just that much yeah that do
they watch the show yeah you never give
commentary feedback possibly negative
yes the they have watched the show but I
have to sit there I mean because the
other West is incredibly quality
sometimes that's what I mean that's a
naughty but there's other words it's not
great for a middle-aged its mom's
sometimes I get stopped by I like people
that are the same age as my mom going
love your show too is the I'm always
fascinated about like the worst or not
worse but just the most standout moments
that you've had with someone that
stopped you in in real life yeah it's
probably I mean this is a serious one
really but I think because we we tackled
a depression storyline in season two and
the amount of response positive response
and openness yeah I think conversation
conversation I think everyone's initial
aim when it comes to talking about
mental health or talking about
depression in any way is your your first
advice is to talk about it talk to
someone about it
and take away all stigma and and just
use intelligence and communication to to
better your situation and that humbles
me so much that people would stop and go
I had some troubles and your show really
helped and that's like the most
rewarding things especially from a
comedy may it's of course it was
brilliantly written but I just
it allowed people to realize that
they're not alone in in any sort of
condition that they feel they might have
reigned that's like the true kind of I
think business of art is to allow people
to not feel alone right it's like to
connect people on different levels and
especially a show like that that does
have such a strong comedic element to be
able to tackle something so serious and
just like bring a conversation to the
forefront that makes people feel less
beholden or less like weighted down with
their own troubles is so important and
it must have felt kind of bonkers to
like create so like to act in that world
and to like have that weight of being
like I want to make sure that this is
the message just carried out this is my
message and that that was your the worst
unfortunately we were nominated for
awards but we never really won any
awards apart from one which was the most
rewarding one ever which was a mental
health organization gave us the award
for the best television depiction of
clinical depression ever and I was like
sold yeah take your Emmys that makes
sense
because we work so hard on that and I
actually I really struggled that season
because I I'm playing someone who really
doesn't understand but as as me yeah
yeah I'm I'm playing the majority of
people who don't suffer from anything in
that I'm just trying to fix you that's
all Jimmy was trying to do regression he
needed to fix her so that things could
get back to normal and when she explains
to him that it doesn't work that way I'm
I'm excited to speak to people who have
been a partner of or a family relative
of someone who's going through something
and see whether that season changed it
for them yeah in your character that
they understood where your point of view
is coming from yeah there is no there's
no like bottle
it's a thing that continues and our
ability to manage that mm-hmm is that
the best achievement that we can all
hope for yeah I think manage is the best
way to phrase that chew up because it's
not fixing it's managing it's it's it's
handling it's living with its you know
all of that and to be able to do that
but still retain like the the voice of
the show and still retain the comedy and
still like give the perspective that you
guys give is like a true testament to
everyone that works on the show I mean
like that's I'm sorry for whatever you
work on in the future I know you're
working to Pokemon movie we're going to
get to that go in on depression let's
talk about Pokemon clinical depression
to axing with tennis balls no but I
think that's one of the greatest
takeaways of the show that you guys get
to like you know kind of and it will
take time to really you absorb the
reverence of like how wonderful that
isn't the message that you guys gave to
everyone else but let's talk about
Pokemon let's talk about Pokemon cuz I'm
obsessed you play pokemon go at all I
did for a short while and then I
realized that everyone else in the world
was playing it and I hate to yeah not to
face it let's get a Prius Oh Prius as
well no I would I would purposely go out
of my way not to join that gang walking
around there was someone at my wedding
we were we were all having the way of
having the group photo and I will send
this to you because it's hilarious photo
hall 150 guests and my cousin is looking
for Mewtwo
I can't I always knew about Pokemon I
never fully appreciated the the scale of
Pokemon its brands I've I mean it's
tilted this I mean I my brothers you
played it when I was younger and I was
like kind of around it but even now my
friends play pokemon go to an obsessive
level same with your cousin and it blows
my mind that how long this brand has
lasted we drink but it does yeah there
was one day on set we were in London and
as one day on set when all the creators
arrived from Japan okay and they all
came over and it was it was like meeting
royalty all the creators of Pokemon to
say yeah they came so were you alerted
of this or this just like no it was kind
of written on the call sheet from the
day before and I went right okay this
entourage of there's only there's only
like seven actors in the whole thing
yeah yeah so obviously Bryan Reynolds
wasn't there because he's the he's a
voice
he's the noise of Pikachu so he wasn't
there so six of us with a group of these
people who have created a life-changing
franchise and they I was wonderful they
they gave us all a gift and I was just
overwhelmed and they it was just a it
was a like a teddy I was about to say
teddy bear is not it's a cuddly toy of
Pikachu's sure and I got home and I was
like oh this is really nice and my son
goes like that and takes it out and then
I saved it because it's a special
edition like there's only 150 of them in
the world well we got one of them so
it's under lock and key
I'm not going anywhere near it but it
was just funny that Freddy went
and also funny for Freddie that daddy
said don't play with this five-year-old
you understand this plushie is important
later but that's not that's really crazy
he's just we've only just started taking
him to the to the theatre really because
now he's fully embracing movies sure I
think he's gonna have his mind blown a
little bit next year when it comes out
yeah 2019
yeah I think it's April May next year
that's so exciting and this would be
will he understand that you like my dad
is in like does he commute he's been
he's been brought up with the whole you
know seeing videos of us on the phone or
photos and all this don't think so if he
sees family in England Modern Family was
shown in England I saw it and Freddie
came in he was like daddy why are you
wearing that carrot a just sees me in
different costumes on the big screen and
who's that girl why are you kissing that
girl he likes her but it's a great job
song it's gonna pay for University don't
it's all good okay we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back we have
Twitter questions for you Chris if you
won't be so obliged you right back with
more not too deep hello beautiful
listeners of the not too deep podcast
just a quick reminder from your hosts
and the voice you've been listening to
quack up until now that if you haven't
already subscribed to the podcast on
iTunes please do so and also if you want
to do us a really cool clutch favor go
in on your subscription rate the podcast
review the podcast it really helps us
out it helps us get just more awareness
from people that wouldn't necessarily
see us you know ratings and comments and
buzz in general are really helpful so if
you're enjoying this at all please leave
your honest
we love to read them leave a rating do
all that fun stuff you know make your
voice heard 2019 we're we're willing to
listen
ish we are bad okay Chris before we get
into Twitter questions I'm gonna ask you
the two questions ask every single guest
that is on the podcast
the first is who alive or dead would you
most like to throw cold spaghetti at I
know that's good yeah thank you
well apart from certain political
figures I won't go there and keep this
not deep I would I would have to say and
it can be in a positive light
yes you celebrated like celebratory this
is good I would say Gordon Ramsay I
think we haven't had that answer yet
that's a great answer yes very good
hypothetically throwing cold spaghetti
and everyone else's face on see how he
feels I would love to see that you
probably complained about the pasta
upsetting factor to it okay the other
question I ask everyone is to tell us
your worst pants [ __ ] story or like
a close call but you can only use three
words or a small phrase so like mine for
example okay is college/university
jogging front lawn okay good I'll go
first date velvet suit bus there are so
many textures
well no follow-up questions thank you so
much for that um I also love that you
just immediately had a story because
some people don't and it's a little
spaghetti but pooping myself a story for
you okay now let's get into these
Twitter questions someone to know were
there any times on your the worst where
you feared your character did something
that went too far or that the audience
would really turn on him yeah pretty
much every day pretty much every day
there was either a speech either he said
that said something or did something
that I'm you know kind of going
[Music]
yes every day cuz something was
offensive offensive or misguided or
something and I think that was the
hardest part of the role to find a
reason why find some humanity in there
somewhere
yeah because I knew the writers are so
clever that they were gonna explain why
he behaved that way
Brahe why he said what he said and I
knew there was a he says and does awful
things but it's not bad human just he's
just the worst sometimes he's not bad
he's just the worst he's not evil it's
not dangerous he's just he just says and
does stupid things because he's fed up
with society but I yeah I think my main
job was to try and find a little bit of
softness in that hard exterior I think
that's so important especially in the
age in which we live in right now and in
America to say the least so I have
adopted a new thing where I'm really
trying to people people annoy you on a
daily basis there's just life you annoy
other people on daily basis that's just
life if if you have an opportunity to
try and take a step back and go is there
a reason that they're doing that then I
think that can make you a better person
I think you can just investigate if
someone goes someone's ride up your back
in in the traffic or whatever and
they're beeping and all that
our human instinct is to fight back or
to hate them yeah and actually yeah some
of the time they are just idiots but
sometimes it's like oh what's gone on I
do I wonder like had a really bad day
yeah what's going on they're a wonderful
philosophy to live by um I mean if you
want to spend this time off in between
projects writing a book about you know
self-help I might buy it so just putting
that out there okay someone to know if
you could live in a fictional universe
from a movie TV show or book which would
you choose
back to the future to 2015 2015 version
of okay you know there's hoverboards and
everything's flying I would love to go
there as we realistic it's probably a
good hundred years off any anything that
happened in that movie happening there
but yeah to hang out with Marty McFly in
Hill Vale Hill Valley from from 2015
would be pretty dope I think that should
happen pre dope by the way I say dope I
have a question on top of that if there
was a reprise of a movie or franchise
that you would want to be in what would
it be
home alone really maybe you would play I
played the father there's a British home
alone where it's all meant to be going
to London but we ended up in Manchester
something like that alone is like he'll
be fine he's got cans and tins
he'll be fine of home alone backs of
future that can think that's what I grew
up on is real up to no good love that
all these contraptions and yeah so you
know
yeah
all the Goonies okay for that as well I
mean I think all this should happen Jack
can we put in some calls
yeah you got a remake of The Goonies
would be would be insane yeah there's an
insane cast yeah like I forgot all of
the like famous people in them I met
Sean Astin a thing couple of years ago
we were playing bowling an FX event
everything that he's done and you know
Lord of the Rings and everything that's
the one movie
he's a Goonies guy yeah he's the Goonies
guy yeah
and that's me and then look like Josh
Brolin
yeah just Brolin I know it's crazy yeah
did you win it bowling no I'm heavily
inconsistent at bowling as I am with all
sports you know I think that's the most
relatable way to be about sports yeah
you don't want to be the best you don't
be the worst you're just buying average
[Laughter]
worst friend's character do you watch
friends mm-hmm okay Phoebe yeah is a
tricky there's a tricky dynamic here
right because I've started watching
friends a lot recently probably because
I've been hung over a lot recently
because I've just finished the show yeah
and I've started from the beginning
uh-huh and I started doing this thing
where I'm watching I'm watching the
first episode in the last episode okay
Cheers
Frasier and Friends oh wow and looking
at like how the cast has changed how the
production values have changed all these
all over these many seasons anyway I'm
watching I'm watching friends Phoebe I
mean Lisa Kudrow's fantastic actress
sure and I love when she's being Phoebe
Phoebe but when she's put with Joey
there's an interesting dynamic because
they're both the kind of the funny ones
and the quote dumb one is the dumbest
was the flighty yeah yeah when they put
together only one of them can really be
the dumb one yeah so when she becomes
the straight one uh-huh I go oh no I
want her to become the silly one again
so that's the only one that jars with me
a little bit is so interesting dynamic
between those two but I don't think you
can dislike any of them you know but I
be so curious to watch the first and
last episode of Friends because Ross I
feel like as a character starts like a
normal human being and then becomes a
full cartoon by the end of it like he
needs actual like therapy help by the
end of it and no one is stepping in like
they all just become nurses ten years
and no one else went and sat on that
sofa in Central Perk it's always just
there's just I mean and Gunther okay um
so let's to know how do you like to eat
pickles write your story about pickles
oh no I can't eat pickles anymore
anymore so there's a moment in time
where you could our showrunners wife and
I were in New York for an event and
someone had just introduced me to pickle
Beck's
juice and it is a magic trick in your
mouth it makes the whiskey go away it
just seems like you're a tasting sour
pickle juice and when you wake up in the
morning it's like you've been punched in
the head yeah yeah and since then I
can't I can't touch him because it
reminds me the PTSD yeah yes sensory
kind of like reminder of the worst
hangover I've ever had what's your go-to
hangover cure if you have one soup soup
soup okay I just for future editing so
get just that clip of I love soup that I
can use as the promo for this whole
episode gets crazy you mixing it up you
got different textures
don't get me started on the the
accompanying bread whoa we going like a
like a French stick that's been forget
about gonna heat it slightly a bit of
crusty roll you're getting really a flag
yeah it's um quite possibly the easiest
its food put into a liquid so you can
eat it without teeth I'm putting stuff
in my body okay I hope someone says as a
fan of you're the worst and Pokemon
detective Pikachu what would be Jimmy's
favorite Pokemon oh nice one probably
Bulbasaur oh he's a big old thing ruff
quite strong there was a there was a day
when we we had to imagine all these
different creatures I do so much
research you did a lot with you said the
CGI tennis balls like yeah Ironman all
different shapes and sizes I don't even
know as someone that's grown up around
them I don't know how they equates like
real life like how big is a Bulbasaur
how BIG's a piece - this is all the
questions that we were trying to
establish and so and obviously these
things do not exist in reality share for
they're just eyelines so right when
we're looking at these things there's
some really thin and tall or small or
massive flying right so one of the
scenes I just remember the whole day I
was literally going just look over to my
cast mate to see whether they're looking
at the same spot because you don't want
to be like 10 of them that they're all
looking at it
well that makes me even more excited I
can't wait I wanted to see this team it
looks like you're having a seizure but
you're just trying to maintain High Line
time
oh wait Chris we've come to the end of
the episode thank you so much for making
time for this but we like to give every
guest that gives us their time a very
personalized fortune cookies are being
on the episode so this is for you
specifically of course all right got a
break yeah sure
sure a strong you are okay what do I do
here you can read it out loud you'd like
to [ __ ] off but not in the playful
British Way so it's not as offensive
right oh my god we're sorry we take it
back yeah what are weird fortune I mean
that's just for you that's our thank you
for being here where can people find you
online where when there's a show the
last season premiering when no Modern
Family is on ABC well that'll be over
Modern Family yes again then FX X will
be showing you're the worst in January
amazing 13 amazing episodes and then
Pokemon will be hopefully in the summer
stay tuned everybody and go follow Chris
and always social media platforms cos he
posts some interesting posts also follow
his wife who will be on an upcoming
episode of not too deep I cannot wait
for Jenna be here thank you again Chris
so much this is so fun
we'll see you guys next time on another
episode about two deep goodbye two deep
deep deep deep not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
a producer and directed by Jack ferry
producer and editor
Melissa demons writing by Diane King
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]